[音楽]
[拍手]
はいどうもこんばんは
はい今日は私はですね天文学と現代社会と
いう話をさせていただくわけなんです
けれどもその中でですね3つほど
メッセージを伝えたいと思っておりますで
ここにですね今
太陽と地球の絵が出てきましたけれども
これ皆さんだいたい大きさってこんな
もん
と思いますかもう笑われてる方も
いらっしゃいますけどねこれ実際の大きさ
に大きさを日に直してみるとどうなるかと
いうとこんな感じです
これ見えますか
大きさで言うと
太陽というのは地球の100倍ぐらいある
わけですで
実際にその対応をと地球がどれくらい離れ
ているかというとこの太陽が100個分
くらい入っていてその先にこの見えない
ような地球があるような感じになり
でさらにですね
太陽系というものを考えてみるとどうなる
かというと
太陽の周りを水星金星地球火星の世界陽性
が回って
冥王星と書いてますけれども今
惑星というと海王星まで
準惑星ということになってますがさらに
もっと言うとですね
太陽系外縁天体っていうのは
広がっていたりするんですけれどもまあ
ちょっと伝統的な話に従って
冥王星までというふうなことで考えてい
ますでこの
太陽と
冥王星までの距離が10mになるまで宇宙
全体に小さくしてきたとしますだいたい
その中学校とか高校とかの教室がですね
だいたい縦の長さが9メートルぐらいです
なのでその教室を思い浮かべてですね一方
の端っこのあたりに
太陽が
でそのもう1本端っこあたりを冥王星が
グーッと回っていくという風な感じになる
まで宇宙全体と
圧縮してきたとしましょう
はいそうするとですね
太陽の大きさ地球の大きさ
太陽地球の間の距離これ想像できます
想像できますか
答え出しちゃいますけれどもだいたいです
ね
太陽の半径で1mmです地球はその
1/100なので1/100mm
という話で
太陽の地球の間が25cm
なのでこの半径1mmの太陽の周りを
0.01mmの目に見えない治療方法
になりますでやっと
冥王星がその方法を端から
これと同じ縮尺でですね
目に見える一番近い腰
までの距離どれくらいになるか
想像できるでしょう
答え70キロぐらいになりますだいたい
東京からだけど小田原ぐらいの感じ分かり
ましたね
宇宙っていうのは本当にそのこんな小さい
けれどもですねピカピカ光ってる宝石
みたいな
天体があってそれが何十曲おきに
ポツポツ
その間には本当に何にもないもう目に見え
ないかもしれませんよね
そんな空間が広がっている場所なんですね
しかしですねここで重要なのはですね実は
太陽と
星っていうのは本質的に全く同じもので
あるということ
です
ね太陽ってやったばかりですよねでも
輝いてるぐらいのもので
暗いですよねなんですけどもこれ実はです
ね自分で核融合反応をして光っている
エネルギーを作り出して光っているという
意味で全く同じものですで本来同じ明るさ
同じような明るさの問題はずなんですね
なんでこんだけ
だいたい
太陽地球の間の距離に比べて太陽から腰
までよりも30万倍ぐらいあるということ
になるその距離だけの話なんですねでこの
数十キロおきに宝石がボツボツになるよう
な感じの宇宙
状況でもですね宇宙全体で見ると
星が密集している場所です
集まっている場所ですそれが
銀河という名前で呼ばれるものですねで
我々の対応あるいは地球みたいなものが
含まれている銀河のことを天の川銀河と
言いますこの天の川銀河この中だけで
星の数
太陽みたいな星の数だけでまあ2000億
個とかいう風な星の数があるという風に
考えられますでさらに目で見える可能性が
あるですね
宇宙の広さで考えると
1000億とか
星の集まりである銀河その銀河が
1000億個ぐらいあるであろうという風
に考えられているというですね何が言い
たいかというとですね
宇宙とんでもないわけ
こういう話をするとですね
こう感想とかを書いてもらうとなんか
すごい人間がちっぽけなもんなんだなって
いうのがよくわかりましたみたいな感じで
書く人はいっぱいいらっしゃい
ますとても正しいですその通りですその
通りなんですけれどもですねしかし人間
っていうのはですね頭の中でこのとんでも
なく広い宇宙っていうのも考えることが
できるんですね
人間の想像力っていうのはそれぐらいの
可能性を秘めてるものであるというのが私
からはまだ最初のメッセージになりますで
次太陽の話に進めていきます
太陽っていうのはピカピカに光っている
ものですねでそのエネルギーによって地球
上の生物は全て生かされているというわけ
です
太陽の光のエネルギーを使って光合成で
植物がエネルギーを作りますそれを装飾
動物が食べるそれを肉食動物が食べる人間
みたいな罰則のものでは全部食べちゃう
ということで地球上にいる生物の
エネルギーというのは全て基本的に太陽の
エネルギーから来ているわけです
もし太陽がですね今突然光らなくなったら
どうなるかそうします
ねという風なことになりますそれぐらい
ですね
太陽のエネルギーはバカでかくてですね
その恩恵を受けて地球上を生物では生活し
ているわけです
なおですけれどもですね
太陽が与えてくれるものというのは恩恵
だけではない
ここに戻したような感じで対応表明でです
ねものすごい爆発現象が起こったりします
フレアと呼ばれますこの
図でお分かりのようにですね
ようなものがあったりするわけですで
さっき言ったように太陽の大きさっていう
のは地球の100倍の大きさがあると言い
ましたけどもということはですねこの大き
さが増えてる物っていうのは
地球の何十倍もあるような大きさのものが
こんなことが
起こるわけですでさらにその吹き出てくる
ものこれですね実は太陽っていうのは基本
的に水素の塊で水素バスの塊だと思ってい
ますでこの水素ガスを進んでくる時にです
ね
水素イオン
プラスの電気を水素イオンとマイナス電気
を電子これ以降は分かれてですね
吹っ飛んでいくような感じになっています
すなわち
巨大な電気のエネルギーとか次の
エネルギーとかも含めてですねこれが宇宙
空間なんかを飛んでいくような感じになる
わけです
それが
急に当たると
どうなるかもちろんあるんですよあるん
ですけども本当に直結するようなことが
ありますどうなる
綺麗な話としてはオールなんですね
多分北の方とかですねで光ってるように
見える空気が
きれいなそれだけそれでいいんですけども
ですね実はそれだけではなくて本当に巨大
なエネルギーの電気とか時期を持ったもの
が飛んでくるのですねそれによってその
電線にですねやたら巨大な電流がドーン
落ちてですね家の中にある電気製品に
コーンとこうダメージを与えてしまう
とかいう風な言葉ありえますし雷が落ち
てる感じですしあるいはですね
実際起こった話ですけども
1989年カナダをケベック州でですね
変電所変電所をですね変圧器が
600万人ぐらいの人が9時間にわたって
停電してしまうという風なことが実際に
あったりしましたあるいはですね地球の
空気はふわっと温まってふわっとこう上昇
してそうするとそこで空気を漂って電波を
飛ばしていたのがですね思ったところ電波
がどんどんなくなって通信障害がですね
あるいは空気をふわっと
上がっていくことによって人工衛星がこの
中を通っている空気が
上がってくるもんで空気抵抗が増えて
勢いを失って落ちちゃう実際に起こった
ものですこんなことがあり得るわけです
フレアによって出てくるエッグセンターが
紫外線とかで
地球への影響っていうのも大きくなる可能
性が高くなってくるわけですねでこれまで
観測された一番大きなエネルギーのフレア
ぐらいのものが
起こるとですね地球上で200兆円規模の
被害が出る可能性があるというのをですね
2008年NASAが研究報告として
出して今現在ですねこれも15年前の話
ですからその時よりももっと電気あるいは
通信というものに体力生活になっているの
でもっとひどい被害が出る可能性がある
のは基本的にエネルギーが大きくなれば
なるほどその頻度は下がっていくことが
太陽の研究で分かっていますですが
これまでの太陽の研究の歴史ってまだ
100年ってそんなもんです
数百年数千年1万年とかいう規模で見ると
もっとごついプレーヤーが起こる可能性が
あるかもしれないですねでこれは研究
しようしなあかんってことになるわけなん
ですけれどもすごい関西弁ですいません
太陽でですね怒るの待ってられるわけです
ね
考えるわけです天文学者考えるわけです
範囲を1個10万年
研究するのですね
太陽に似た欲しい最初に言った通りで太陽
として同じものなので体力欲しいっていう
のは存在してこれ10万個ですね1年関節
が似たようなものなのかという風な話に
なりますで実際にですねこれ非常に
タイミングのいいことにその研究にですね
やったらよく使えるんですねケプラを宇宙
望遠鏡のデータというのは公開されました
で
我々のグループはそのデータを解析した
ところですね
そのこれまで観測された最大級の太陽
フレアの10倍以上下手したら1万倍とか
のエネルギーが
起こってるよ分かっちゃったわけです
でですね
怒るんだったらそれはちょっとスーパー
フライ怒ってる腰ちゃんとテレビ調べなあ
今の
段階でいろいろ調べているわけなんです
けどこんな感じで
太陽っていうのは本当にその
今回地球上に東西線を生命全てに対する
リスクというのになれる可能性があるわけ
ですでそれぞれですね今我々はスーパー
フレイムこそというのはどういう星なのか
太陽って本当に似てると言えるのか全然
違うんですねあるいはスーパーフレアが
起こるんだとしたらその予兆現象は何で
あるとかあるいは
その辺はよく調べていてちょっとした
応用的な話として地球に本当に
被害があるとしたら具体的にどんな弊害が
あるのかあるいは防災が可能かという風な
感じのことを調べて将来的に調べていけれ
ばいいかなというふうに思っております
これが2つ目のメッセージなわけなんです
けども今すごく怖がらせる中で言いました
けどですねあの今すぐ
危険というわけではないんですけども
よく分かる必要はありませんというところ
は一応覚えている
で最後にですねこれ私の大好きな言葉なん
ですけれどもアンダー1世代国際天文学
連合というのがですね2019年に
創立100周年を迎えましたその時の標語
ですあなたは扱い日本語で1つダウンし
たってですねで日本語では
昔から一つ屋根の下という言葉があります
一つ屋根の下のうちで家族のように
あるいは家族同然として仲良く暮らすと
いう
わけです
我々は地球上をどこにいてもですねどんな
肌の様子でいてもですねどんなことを
しゃべっていてもあるいはどんな文化背景
があったとしてもですね同じ太陽を見て
同じ月を見て同じ星を見てっていう本当に
一つ空の下で暮らしているですねまあ生物
なわけですいろいろですね最近いろいろ
地球上でいろいろ企画されることがあり
ますけれどもですね色々起こっております
けれどもですねもっとですね長い目で見る
あれはもっと大きな姿勢に立ってですね一
つ空の下で暮らす家族同然でもいいですね
なっていけるようにしていきたいなという
ふうに思いますこれが私からの3つ目の
メッセージですはい私の話はこれは
ありがとうございました
[拍手]